Right, same idea, same technique, just with a direction change — the so-called exam-eight, or, on the exam, designated as P2.
Here too, we start along a track: we fly a completely closed left circle. On the exam we always start with the left circle.
Then on our track, directly linked into it, comes the right circle.
That means the two circles are flown slightly offset from each other along a guide-line, and that's why it's called the exam-eight,
because it looks a bit like an offset figure-eight. It has nothing to do with a written figure 8 — these are two fully closed circles.
Also watch that when you reach the track — meaning on your flight path the direct change comes —
you don't need to fly straight, along that guide-line, and then come a (unclear)
and try both out, and go with whichever feels better to you.
On the exam at the launch site we look for the area of least sink, we check the airspace, the airspace is clear, the left circle comes,
weight in to the left, right hand all the way up.
Just before we're back on our line, body weight already comes across, then on our line the brake comes, and then the direct change snaps into the right circle.
Then we finish the right circle almost completely, and just before we're on the track, the body goes into the neutral sitting position and at the same time relaxes,
so we pull the outer brake slowly, properly full, and the outer brake comes in so that we exit this whole thing slightly braked, at the right moment.
Here too, time isn't the first priority — flight path, flight path is — and the same applies for the double-circle as well.
Flight path is first priority: orientation in space, setting bank angle, weight shift and so on.
Time comes later. The more we've practised the whole thing, the more comfortable we feel when the bank angle is set a bit steeper.
And so we go into the neutral sitting position and bang, bring in the outer brake so that we come out slightly braked again.
As soon as we have that, we can also release the brake fully again.
On the figure-eight it often happens that you initiate the first circle quite briskly.
Then comes the changeover and you mostly almost do the manoeuvre over to this side and then get into trouble,
after the first input. So watch that you work directly with the outer brake at the changeover.
Meaning, when I now come in here, bang, just before I'm on my line, the outer hand comes with the weight harmonically,
so that I'm actually braked at the right moment on my track, and then comes the harmonic direct changeover.
But again, always handle the outer brake. The outer brake is an important element when flying circles.
Should we ever end up in a spiral — bite me — or simply in a very strong bank angle on the double circle,
we never release the inner hand, but go with it.
Via the outer brake, far enough down until we cleanly come out of the whole thing.
That's a really important element, and that's what it's about.
For the figure-eight manoeuvre, a prescribed flight path is taken up.
By measured pulling of the left brake line, a left circle is flown until the wing is back on the original flight path.
With measured pulling of the right brake line, a right circle is then flown until the wing is back on the original flight path.
By measured braking, subsequent roll and pitch movements are caught and the wing is stabilised.
Caution!
On the direction change, pulling the brake line too hard or wrong timing can lead to a one-sided stall.
The time limit for the manoeuvre is a maximum of 25 seconds. Important!
Time measurement only stops when the wing is flying stably on the original flight path.